Moscow under drone attack for the second
time in three days this is amateur
footage that goes viral on social media
it hardly mirrors the devastation caused
by missiles hitting buildings in Ukraine
but the damage caused by drones in the
Russian capital is a visible reminder
that the war is not entirely confined to
areas outside its borders
we were going to see the tower where the
explosions happened the day before
yesterday
and people showed us where it happened
and then suddenly there was this
explosion and we immediately ran the
same high-rise building was struck on
Sunday in moscow's central business
district it houses three government
departments and prompted a senior
advisor to Ukraine's president
follodimir zielinski to warn that Moscow
should expect more and while the Russian
defense Ministry said the drones had
been shot down the Kremlin admitted
drone strikes were an ongoing threat
I have nothing to add to what the
defense Ministry has already said
yesterday I told you that only the
military can and should comment on this
in terms of an expert point of view
indeed the threat exists it is obvious
but measures are being taken there have
been several drone attacks on Moscow
since this incident in early May when
two drones were fired at the Kremlin
complex itself
it flew into the building it was about
that size but the most important thing
is that the glass can be replaced
everyone is alive and okay
it may not feel like War exactly but nor
does it square with the kremlin's claim
that its so-called special military
operation in Ukraine is proceeding
according to plan
Jonah Hall Al Jazeera
foreign